the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lecture today is called
Rolle's Theorem and its consequences and
I suppose we could have made a take-off
on what goes up must come down and say
that what Rolle's Theorem says
intuitively is that what goes up
smoothly and comes down smoothly must
level off somewhere okay now because
that may sound too easy to understand
let's cloak that in the language of more
formal mathematics Rolle's Theorem says
this let F be defined and continuous on
the closed interval from A to B in other
words what the domain of F is the closed
the rules may to be the graph of F is
unbroken on this interval and
differentiable in the open interval from
A to B in other words you want the
function to be continuous on the entire
interval but for differentiability you
only require that it be smooth
differentiable in the interior of the
interval in the open interval suppose
also that F of a and F of B are 0 then
what rolle's theorem says is that F
prime of C the derivative of f of X must
be 0 for some number C at least one
number C in the interval the open
interval from A to B now what this thing
says intuitively is simply this suppose
you have a curve that is unbroken for
all values of X between a and B
inclusively suppose the curve is smooth
suppose the curve starts here and ends
here then what we're saying is there
must be some point in here where the
curve levels off in other words
someplace where you have a horizontal
tangent which is what F prime of C
equals 0 means in this particular
diagram this would be the value of C
that we're talking about by the way I
think the proof is intuitively clear
namely if the curve never leaves the
x-axis then it's leveled off for the
entire domain and if the curve does
leave the
x-axis for example suppose the curve
starts to rise okay since it must
eventually get back to the x-axis when B
is zero it must ultimately begin to fall
again well if the curve goes from rising
to falling it must have what since it's
coming up and then going down it must
attain a maximum value because the curve
is unbroken and smooth as we saw in our
previous lecture the maximum value is
characterized by the derivative at that
point being zero in fact the analytic
proof is precisely what we've just said
only translated into more mathematical
language by the way I would like to make
a slight aside here because I think it
sometimes gets confusing to students to
see why do you say that the function has
to be continuous on the closed interval
but differentiable only in the open
interval I thought you might like to see
a contrived example as to what goes
wrong if you allow the curve to be
broken at the endpoints C all I'm
thinking of is something like this
suppose I say look at let's define a
curve as follows at x equals a and x
equals B the curve will be 0 so you know
it'll cross the x-axis then immediately
for X greater than a the curve jumps up
to here comes down along this line and
then you see when x equals B it jumps
down here again in other words why not
let the curve be defined as follows it
will be 0 at these two end points it'll
be this curve in on the open interval
notice in this contrived example that F
of a and F of B are both equal to 0 but
there is no place in the open interval
where the curve has a horizontal tangent
line in other words the significance is
you've got to be sure that the curve
doesn't get broken at the ends because
with these gaps all sorts of crazy
things can happen now just as in our
previous lecture there are some rather
important cautions that have to be taken
in understanding Rolle's Theorem as
simple as it is we have to be sure
that we understand exactly what's really
happening here the first caution is that
rolls theorem is what we mathematicians
call an existence theorem it says under
certain conditions there exists at least
one number C that has a certain property
it doesn't tell us how many C's there
are it doesn't tell us where to find
them it just says what there exist at
least one such C and the point is you
must be careful to remember so let's
take an example his a his B if the
function is continuous and smooth nor
was if the graph is continuous and
smooth all we're saying is that at least
one number between a and B the curve
must possess a horizontal tangent there
may be more than one you see the curve
for example could do something like this
C in other words here is one value of C
which we'll call C one horizontal
tangent here here's another value which
we'll call C two horizontal tangent here
see again the meaning of at least one
secondly
we must make sure that we remember that
the curve is smooth meaning what that
the function is differentiable now I'm
taking the liberty of drawing these
things in freehand there's some mixed
emotions here if I draw the diagrams too
smoothly all the time you lose the
significance of what's going on because
of the picture and if I drum freehand
all the time
you won't understand what I'm doing
because I don't draw very well but I
think here we can get away with this
what I'm driving at is this let's
suppose you have a and B here let's
suppose that the function the curve that
we're drawing passes through these two
points but suppose that happens to be a
sharp corner in here and maybe the curve
goes like this it goes up like this then
very abruptly comes down like this
notice what that the curve is continuous
it does reach a local maximum but the
point is for this particular value of C
f prime of C is not 0 by default namely
F prime of C doesn't even exist so in
other words the Rolle's Theorem doesn't
apply if you don't have
differentiability so I want you to make
sure you see where each of the parts of
the hypotheses for the theorem are used
by the way here's another interesting
result which has nothing to do with the
statement of the theorem but again
another piece of evidence as to why lis
we like to shy away from functions which
are not single value C for example
suppose you allowed the function to be
multi valued and you say okay I want the
curve to pass through here and here and
I wanted to be smooth but the function
does not the curve doesn't have to be
single value notice that what you can do
you can have a curve that there's
something like this I don't know
now you see there will be a point see
where the derivative will be zero
even as badly as I've drawn this I think
roughly speaking we can see that C would
be something like this notice however
that in rolle's theorem the statement is
what that C must be on the open interval
from A to B if the function is not
single valued as long as the curve is
smooth there will be places where the
curve levels off but the point the
x-coordinate of the point at which the
curve levels off may not be in the
interval may not be it could be but it
may not be might not be I should say in
the open interval from A to B this is a
very very important result fact I'll
have reason to make reference to this in
a little while later in the lecture
I couldn't make reference to it later
earlier in the lecture I guess but look
at the fourth assumption here is also an
aside and it's one that's rather crucial
in most textbooks in which rolls theorem
is stated the condition is what that F
of a equals F of B equals zero it turns
out that this is too restrictive that
essentially all you need is F of a
equals F of B but I'm what I mean by
that is is let's suppose f of a is not
zero let's suppose this height
represents F of a what I'm saying is
suppose that F of a and F of B are equal
what that means is if I want to think of
a new axis which I can call the X sub
one axis C with respect to the X sub one
axis the curve crosses the axis at these
two points in other words notice that as
long as these two points they're at the
same level
the same argument that we use to prove
rolls theorem goes through unimpeded
over here namely we say what what goes
up smoothly and comes down smoothly
because it has to come down because it
comes back to the same level here must
reach a point someplace in here where it
levels off so these are the four
cautions that I'd like you to you look
at when we view Rolle's Theorem
now if somebody were to say to us what's
so important about roles theorem and
this happens so often in mathematics
that frequently the most important thing
about one particular theorem is that it
may be the building block by which a
more important or more useful or more
practical theorem is derived and in this
respect I would say from my own opinion
that the most important application of
rolls theorem is that it facilitates a
very famous result known as the mean
value theorem as our course proceeds
from time to time we will have ample
reason to backtrack and make references
to the mean value theorem
I intend not to make too deep references
to the mean value theorem now because
what I would like to do is to establish
the result give you enough of an
intuitive feeling so that you can tuck
it under your belt without feeling too
overwhelmed by it and just enough
applications of it so that we can get
into the next phase of our calculus
course but the mean value theorem is
another one of these things where if you
state the thing analytically and have no
feeling for what's going on pictorially
the thing can become overwhelming let's
in fact do it in an overwhelming way and
then show what the thing means
pictorially notice again how this thing
now starts off the same way as rolle's
theorem let F be continuous on the
closed interval from A to B and
differentiable in the open interval from
A to B by the way this is just the
idiosyncrasy of mine I don't know if
it's standard when I talk about the
closed interval I have the habit of
saying on the interval when I talk about
the open interval I like to say in the
interval to sort of emphasize the
interior it's just a vocabulary trait
and don't read too much into this don't
be upset by it but this continuous on
the closed interval differentiable in
the open interval now it's again an
existence theorem it says then there
exists a number C and when I say there
exist that means what there is at least
one number C in the open interval from A
to B and this is the part that looks
kind of tough such that F of B minus F
of a divided by B minus a is F prime of
C and this somehow or other
seem at first glance to be more ominous
than the intuitive feeling about rolle's
theorem by the way as the name implies
whereby mean we don't mean nasty we mean
average if you'd like to see what this
thing means now draw you a picture in a
second all it says is that if a particle
is moving from point A to point B say at
at least one point during its trip the
instantaneous speed must equal the
average speed you see because after all
if you were always going less than your
average speed how could you have had an
average speed as high as your average
speed and if you're always going less
than your average speed how could you
have had you see an average speed
equaling this what it did so that
somehow or other all you're saying is is
that the somehow or other the
instantaneous speed at a particular
instant must equal your average speed
someplace along the path now what that
means pictorially is this again I'll
chance a freehand diagram suppose our
curve is y equals f of X see I've drawn
it to be smooth suppose it's continuous
and smooth on this open interval from A
to B now what is if I think of a
particle moving from point P to point Q
how do I dent how do I identify the
average speed the average speed is the
slope of a straight line that joins P to
Q on the other hand what is the
instantaneous speed if we think of it in
terms of a picture it's the slope of the
line tangent to the curve at a
particular point so in other words what
we're saying is this you see if we were
to take the line PQ and we shift it
parallel to itself I think you can sense
that the points P and Q if we label P
and Q the points at which this court
intersects the curve the points P and Q
will roll in closer and closer together
ultimately the line will fail to
intersect the curve and at the
transition point if the curve is smooth
all we're saying is is that the last
point at which
that line touches the circle the curve
as we move it out okay that the line
would be tangent to the curve at that
particular point this thing that's all
we're saying is what that someplace
between here and here there must be a
point where the tangent line to the
curve is parallel to the court PQ and
now we have all the ingredients that we
need to see what the mean value theorem
says geometrically let's call the
tangent line L first of all what is the
slope of the line PQ well its depth it's
a straight line the slope of a straight
line is Delta Y divided by Delta X well
notice that this height here is by
definition f of B this height here is f
of a so this height here is just F of B
minus F of a this length here is just
the minus a so the slope Delta Y divided
by Delta X is just F of B minus F of a
over B minus a on the other hand what is
the slope of the line L by definition
its F prime of X evaluated at x equals C
that's F prime of C and what does it
mean in terms of slopes for two lines to
be parallel it means that their slopes
are equal and where is C C is someplace
in the open interval from A to B now the
reason I call this intuitively an
extension of Rolle's Theorem and by the
way you'll notice that what I have to
say is a much simpler demonstration than
what's given in the book but before you
think I'm being egotistical out this let
me point out as is so often the case
that wherever my demonstrations are
easier than the one on the book I'm
losing something in my presentation
either I haven't shown the most analytic
representation or I'm overlooking a
particular complicated side effect that
might occur you see but disregarding
that for the moment you see what I'm
saying is this let's suppose for the
sake of argument we visualize the line
PQ as being our new x-axis I'll call
that the x1
and now let's take a line perpendicular
to PQ and call that our new y axis the
y1 axis now look at the curve that we've
drawn with respect to the Y 1 X 1 axis
notice that the curve is smooth right
it's unbroken and it cuts the X 1 axis
at two points now if we apply rolle's
theorem with respect to the x1 y1 axis
we say look at here's a curve which cuts
the x axis the X 1 axis at two points
it's smooth right therefore it must
level off someplace in other words there
must be some point on this curve where
the tangent line to the curve is
parallel to the X 1 axis that's exactly
you see what this thing here says okay
that's another geometric interpretation
that indicates how Rolle's Theorem might
be used however there is a very very
subtle flaw in what I've said one that
is so subtle that you may not even
notice it until I pointed out to you and
even after I pointed out there's a
chance you may not realize what I've
said because it's a point that I know
took me a long long time to discover for
myself and it all hinges on the concept
of single-valued 'no Segen the trouble
with this interpretation is the
following and by the way let me point
out I'm going I'm not knocking my
interpretation I think it's still a
tremendous way of visualizing the result
but from an analytical point of view why
we have to be careful let's suppose that
my curve y equals f of X happens to look
something like this
ok happens to look something like this
notice barring any bad drawing that I've
done here that this curve is single
value that no line parallel to the y
axis cuts this curve in more than one
place
now here's my a and his might be and so
I say ok by Rawls theorem that if I look
at this as being the x-axis and this is
being the y-axis in other words the x1
y1 axis again I say to myself look at
here's a smooth curve it cuts the x axis
in two points
therefore someplace between these two
points there must be a place where the
curve levels off etc etc etc and the
interesting point is to notice that a
given curve as to whether it's single
value or not is dependent upon the
orientation of the axes in other words
notice that I've drawn this particular
curve so this is single valued with
respect to the XY plane on the other
hand with respect to the x one y one
coordinate system this curve is not
single valued namely observe how aligned
parallel to the y one axis can intersect
this curve at more than one point in
other words whether a curve a single
valued or not is not an absolute
property independent of the coordinate
system so again if I could be sure that
when I rotated my coordinate axes the
the original single valued curve was
still single valued then my above proof
would have been rigorous but of course I
can't be sure of that by the way the
technique used in the book is quite
standard and what it does is the
following it still utilizes rolle's
theorem but the technique behind the
proof in the book is this the function
that we set up is the vertical distance
between the chord and the curve as we
move along this way and notice that that
distance is zero at these two endpoints
okay
and therefore Rolle's Theorem applies to
that function and the whole idea is
something like this all we say is that
and the analytic pot proves this all we
say is look at the point at which this
court would have been tangent to the
curve is the place where the vertical
distance between the chord and the curve
is what maximum and we won't go into
that right now that is done in the text
all I want to do as I always will do
when possible is that whenever the
rigorous proof seems far more
complicated than proofs which are more
intuitive I will not take the time in
general in our lectures to give them
more rigorous proof well I will take the
time to
is to show why the less rigorous proof
has pitfalls well enough said about the
statement of the mean value theorem time
is getting very short and we don't need
much more time to make the homerun ball
pitch that we want to make now and the
idea is this that the most important
analytical reason for having the mean
value theorem is for those of us who
like to use our geometric intuition it
turns out that almost every
geometrically obvious fact that has a
proper analytic counterpart has the
property that the analytic counterpart
is proven by the mean value theorem see
let me give you a simple for instance in
fact in the textbook this is called the
first corollary to the mean value
theorem suppose we have a function
capital f of X and we know that the
derivative is always equal to zero the
claim is that f of X itself must be a
constant by the way two cautions here
don't say that we've had this result
before the result that we had before was
actually the converse of this the result
that we had before was the one that said
what if f of X is a constant then it's
derivative is zero now we're saying the
opposite but the Congress now we're
saying look if the derivative is always
zero notice the use of my identity
symbol here if the derivative is zero
for all values of X then the function
must have been a constant now you know
geometrically this is a very simple
thing to visualize you say look at the
derivative is a slope and if you're
saying that the slope of the curve is
hot is always horizontal the curve
itself must be a straight line and if
the curve is a straight line that's
exactly what you mean by saying that the
function is a constant how do we prove
this using the mean value theorem say
and I just wanted to go through a proof
here once just so you get the idea of
what a proof means you see to show that
something is a constant you mean what
that if a is unequal to be for any two
values a and B f of a while I'm using
capital F here capital F of a
has to equal capital f of B that's what
you mean for a function to be a constant
no matter what the input is the outputs
are always equal okay
by the way if a equals B it's trivial in
F of a equals F of B but essentially to
prove it capital F is a constant
this is what I have to prove that if a
is different from B no matter what a and
B I use that F of a equals F of B and
the idea is by the mean value theorem we
say look at what does the mean value
theorem say it said we're assuming now
that f is a continuous and
differentiable function on interval okay
from A to B the mean value theorem says
under these conditions there exists a
number C between a and B with what
property that F of B minus F of a over B
minus a is equal to F prime of C that's
just a statement of the mean value
theorem this is always true if the
conditions of the mean value theorem
apply now all we're saying is in this
particular problem what property that
capital F had have it had the property
that its derivative for all values of X
was 0 in particular then when C is the
value that we're talking about if f
prime of X is 0 for all values of X in
particular then it's 0 when X is equal
to C in other words by our given
hypothesis this is 0 ok but if the
numerator if a fraction is 0 its
numerator must be 0 that says what F of
B minus F of a is 0 C the only way a
quotient can be 0 is for the numerator
or the divide the dividend the divisor
which I don't know these formal names
they slipped my mind but the top one has
to be 0 and if F of B minus F of a is 0
that says F of B equals F of a and
that's precisely what we had to show to
show that F was a constant okay so again
notice it's not that we're saying that
the mean value theorem is a harder way
of proving what we already know to be
intuitively true is what we're saying is
what that we know
that many intuitively obvious results
frequently turn out to be false we would
like some analytical way of knowing
which of the intuitive results are
actually correct all I'm saying is the
mean value theorem gives us a big hint
that way by the way let me close by
giving you one more important
illustration of what we can prove by the
mean value theorem and this is called a
corollary of a corollary as I'll show
you what I mean in a minute
the next example that I want to use is
what it means to say suppose I'm given
two functions F and G and all I know
about these two functions is that the
derivative are identical in other words
that F and G have the property that for
every value of X F prime of X is equal
to G prime of X by the way when I say
every value of x again it's local versus
global it's not necessary if this
happens for all X what is important is
what that X be defined on some interval
no it's even if I know that this
property is true for some interval I
don't really care what happens outside
of that interval in terms of local
properties all I'm saying is all I know
is that for some interval maybe the
whole axis doesn't make any difference F
prime is identical to G prime now you
would like to be able to say maybe that
if F prime is equal to G prime F equals
G but that's not the case what is the
case is that the difference between the
two functions must be a constant
again geometrically what you're saying
is what that if you have two curves
which point-by-point
always have the same slope in other
words for each x-value the slopes are
the same isn't this essentially saying
that the two curves are parallel and if
the parallel curves what's a way of
staying the two curves are parallel that
one is a constant displacement of the
other now is the geometric impact of two
curves having the same derivative is not
that the curves are the same but that
they're parallel and by the way the
proof of this result is again a
corollary to the mean value theorem
namely let's look at the function f
X minus G of X call that capital F of X
but capital f of X be f of X minus G of
X since the derivative of a difference
is the difference of the derivatives
that would say the derivative of capital
f is little the derivative of little F
minus the derivative of G okay now what
do we know about F Prime and G prime of
X we know that F prime of X equals G
prime of X for all X consequently the
difference between these two must be
zero
remember if two functions are identical
their difference is zero that says
therefore the F capital F prime of X is
identically 0 and by our previous
theorem notice the beautiful logic of
this from the mean value theorem we
proved that if a function is identically
if the derivative of a function is
identically 0 the function must be a
constant so we apply that here but what
was capital F it was little F minus G
and that proves our desired result again
what I want you to see here is that we
have not done anything different with
the mean value theorem we're not trying
to say we're going to prove results we
couldn't prove before rather what the
mean value theorem is our way of showing
that certain intuitive results hold true
analytically that we can't talk about
parallel curves and things like this
most important in terms of summarizing
this lecture from the point of view of
what's coming next it's crucial to
observe that this last example is what
is going to allow us to enter the study
of something called the indefinite
integral or in another manner of
speaking something called the inverse of
taking a derivative you see the idea is
notice that in these two examples we
start with information about the
derivative and deduce what's true about
the original function that's inverting
the emphasis of what we have been doing
up until now where we've started with
the function and investigated its
derivative to see this in more detail
join me again next time and until next
time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate